en hogwarts hay cuatro casas gryffindor
hufflepuff ravenclaw slider y el gráfico
de barras abajo nos muestra el número de
puntos que ganó cada casa el día de hoy
y nos preguntan cuántos puntos recibió
rubén cloud el día de hoy
entonces tenemos aquí esta gráfica donde
vemos que tenemos los nombres de cada
casa gryffindor hufflepuff ravenclaw
slider in y también nos dice cuántos
puntos ha ganado el día de hoy donde
vaya tenemos diferentes cantidades aquí
nos preguntan en específico cuántos
puntos ganó reb en cloud y si nos vamos
aquí podemos ver que ganó 10 20 30
nuestro gráfico de barras nos indica que
ganó 30 puntos vamos a escribirlo
30 puntos ganó la casa el día de hoy
y es correcto vamos a tratar uno más
de la misma manera nos está diciendo de
las cuatro casas y nos pregunta ahora
cuántos puntos ganó gryffindor el día de
hoy tenemos igual nuestras cuatro casas
y los puntos que pudieron haber recibido
vamos entonces a la columna oa la barra
que nos está diciendo cuántos ganó
gryffindor
y tenemos 10 20 30 volvamos a colocar
los 30 puntos comprobamos respuesta y es
correcto